the Joe Rogan experience do you think
that's the truth and what we're doing
right now do you think we're almost
becoming too lenient and then we're
gonna get to the point where like you
know what we have to have some
discipline some discipline yeah to where
I was in the Starbucks the other day I
thought about posting it but I didn't I
actually thought about sending to you
but I didn't but it was it was in the
Starbucks and it said there was a
bathroom that said any sex and there was
a male a woman and a guy in the
wheelchair I'm like since one since when
is a person in a wheelchair a sex like
you know it's almost like they're afraid
to to put something on the door to where
they just make it as broad as possible
right and it's like you know we have to
have we have to have some lines
otherwise it's just nothing but gray
well there's no here's the thing man I
think all this is in response to the
idea that men and women are competing
against each other
I think that's where we got to cut the
[ __ ] I think if this idea that like
there's a different like there's no
doubt that you need women and you need
men we need humans right we need each
other
yep so we got to figure out like why is
everybody so hung up on gender is there
an imbalance and whatever that imbalance
is it's got to be corrected but it's got
to be corrected honorably and it's got
to be corrected honestly yeah we have to
be nice to each other
all of us we like each other girls like
boys boys like girls that's how it's
always been and any aberrations of that
can really [ __ ] your head up but I think
they're more aberrations than they are
the norm and I think we have to figure
out how to make those aberrations lesser
and lesser and no one's concentrating on
that instead they're concentrated on
boys versus girls and I think that's
crazy it's like if you only like men I
can't hang out with you dude you're
gonna say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about
women and I'm gonna go that's my
daughter that's my sister that's my mom
like you can't do that this idea that
like we're on a team and we're on team
dicks team vaginas trying to [ __ ]
steal our gold this is stupid
it's stupid it's stupid we can't do that
anymore just like we can't do team white
people right that's not good either yeah
it's not good team
[ __ ] beige people if you all beige
people all beige people speak Spanish
get on a team come on what are we doing
that's Dutch it's all the same it's
whether it's whether it's sexual
orientation whether it's gay straight
whether it's black white male female
Asian Italian people saying people nice
people interesting people different
people we have to learn that we're in a
global community like who really have to
figure it out and we're closer and
closer than we've ever been before but
along the way we're gonna get ridiculous
[ __ ] we're gonna get like people that
are completely overreacting and all men
are sexist and all men are rapists and
all sex with a penis that a vagina is
rape and it's like there's a lot of that
going on right now but yes those are the
echoes of the forest reaches of the idea
and then that idea will pull back into
the middle and then the general
consensus will be established yeah
that's what people do
[Applause]